it is so much fun to watch you and uh
see
you these three weeks what do you think
that you've learned about yourself matt
during these three weeks
i've learned that i have a lot to learn
um it it it nothing about this has been
easy um it's a lot of patience and just
taking the the
the constructive coaching that you're
getting and not taking anything personal
you know because
everyone here's competitors they're
super at the top of their game whatever
they're doing so like
to not be at the top of something and
the best is frustrating for a lot of
people so just like putting that aside
and just making sure that i'm locking in
and getting the steps i need and just
taking to lindsay's coaching i know
we're gonna be fine
what what have you seen uh kind of
changes have you seen in him lindsay
oh my goodness if you guys could be a
fly on the wall in our first rehearsal
and then see where we are now
it is so cool and it really is my
favorite part about the show is getting
a partner who comes into this with zero
dance experience and seeing them
actually be able to execute performances
on television performing in front of
millions of people and then getting
judged for it like i just really seen
him
from day one find his confidence in the
fact that yes maybe he isn't the best
dancer in the competition
but he puts his best foot forward every
single week and i love that because i
think sometimes like matt was saying
it's like if you're not getting the best
scores sometimes that can be
discouraging but he never lets it get to
him he's always positive always ready to
go and be better the week after so it's
it's really great uh i love that you
revealed that you had a britney poster
on your
no shame
and what would you say like what kind of
inspiration was she for you you know
this this last britney night was fun so
tell me what kind of inspiration she
provided
the coolest thing for me to see to be
honest with you was
these
these pioneers in their field like a
melanie uh sporty spike so jojo who
can really relate to
the journey and trip that brittany's
been on and like though jojo's in her
infancy of it and melanie's someone
who's seen it all the way through like
they had so much respect and homage to
pay to brittany for you know
trailblazing this way for women like
them to
perform and be in the situation that
they're at and they were just had
nothing but love and good things to say
about her and i think
what lindsey and i were talking about is
everything associated with written songs
for us is nostalgic so like we were just
it was a vibe in there tonight the
interview was up and the competition was
stiff
the other thing i really liked was you
see your mom
you know and that you got to give your
mom a message
what was that like for you how you know
when are you going to be able to see her
when is she going to be coming out to
see you in person
she's got to make it back out here she
was fortunately she was here for the
premiere um but it's cool
having lindsay as my partner because not
only is she a pro and
an incredible person but she's a mother
at the end of the day and like a lot of
the qualities that i've seen lindsey are
things that i see in my mom and it's fun
to have that type of relationship where
you know i'm constantly reminded of you
know the sacrifices that you have to
make as a mom
uh
for your your child and i just have so
much respect for
someone like lindsay who's you know
putting
all of that aside to take the time to
teach me you know she's got sage at home
but she's taking hours out of her time
and sacrificing a lot to be here so i'm
just you know honored to have her as a
partner
how did you feel about christine leaving
tonight
it's so hard i genuinely like
from this point forward i have no idea
how it's going to go i feel like there's
usually seasons where the first couple
weeks you kind of see how things are
going to play out but it's so hard and
when it was kenyan for seeing the bottom
like both of them deserve to stay i
don't feel like there was one right or
wrong answer there so it was so hard to
see her go especially knowing how big of
a fan she is at the show but i hope she
just knows how amazing she was this
whole season and she should be so proud
of herself
last question they're they're wrapping
me up i want to ask um next week two two
dances
for disney week how is that gonna be
i mean it's crazy like up until this
point you've only had to do one style
every week and now we gotta do two
and there's two full shows like i really
really really i mean we're gonna do it
it's gonna be amazing everyone's gonna
figure it out but i think people
underestimate how much different that is
going to be for each one of these
celebrities it is
so so difficult and i just am already
giving them all around applause for the
week that they're about to step into
because it's going to be tough intense
there's a lot of work to be done but i
know we're going to get it done